the wreckage of a plane which crashed
with 22 people on board has been located
in the himalayan mountains in nepal
rescuers have so far recovered 14 bodies
from the crash site the plane was
carrying locals and tourists to a
mountain town
photos from deep in the himalayas
confirmed the worst for the missing
flight
the wreckage was discovered in the early
morning a day after the small plane went
missing
multiple bodies have been recovered but
bad weather and the remote location have
made accessing the site difficult
the flight from pakara to the mountain
town of johnson is a popular one with
tourists it normally only takes about 20
minutes
but air traffic control lost contact
with the aircraft shortly after takeoff
now authorities have confirmed that an
accident occurred about five minutes
before the plane was due to land
experts are still assessing the cause of
the crash
the flight seems to have collided with a
big rock on the hill
the twin otter plane similar to the one
shown here was carrying 22 people
including three crew members
the aircraft is operated by tara air
among the 19 passengers are two german
nationals four indians and 13 nepali
citizens
for the families waiting anxiously for
news the discovery of the crash has
realized their worst fears
unpredictable mountain weather and
remote airport locations means that
plane crashes in nepal are not
infrequent